[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute eine
Giotto Erdbeertorte ich fange direkt an
mit meinem fluffigen Vanille
Biskuitboden ich habe so ein Basic
Rezept auf meinem Kanal und ich verlinke
auch gerne auf das Rezept damit er das
Hauptvideo nicht so lang ist aber heute
habe ich mir gedacht habt ihr alles
gebündelt in einem Video ich glaube das
gefällt euch manchmal auch ein bisschen
besser und die ganz genauen
Mengenangaben die schreibt immer und in
die Infobox ähm dann ist das Video nicht
so unnötig lang und ich trenne jetzt
erstmal die Eier kommt das Eiweiß in die
eine Schüssel das Eigelb schlagen wie
separat auf so haben einfach die
maximale Fluffigkeit und das wird dann
zusammen mit der Hälfte des Zuckers und
einer Prise Salz plus Vanilleextrakt 3
Minuten dann cremig geschlagen
[Musik]
so da habe ich einmal nicht aufgepasst
und jetzt ist die Masse schon extrem
steif aber das ist überhaupt nicht
schlimm im Gegenteil es ist sogar sehr
sehr gut muss sagen die Maschine hat
halt echt Power ihr könnt natürlich eure
Handrührgerät verwenden aber so habe ich
mal das Gefühl das Massen noch fluffiger
werden so ich gebe jetzt hier wie schon
gesagt mein Eigelb mit rein die Reste
schön rausschaben nicht verschwinden und
dann restlichen Zucker mit dazu und dann
auch noch mal richtig schön dick cremig
schlagen das dauert auch ungefähr so
zwei drei Minuten mit der Maschine
[Musik]
so das ist jetzt die Eigelb Zuckermasse
sehr schön hell und fluffig geworden und
jetzt nehmen wir uns einen Teigschaber
und geben immer Stück für Stück die
Baisermasse also die Eiweißmasse in die
eigelmasse und dann immer so von außen
nach innen streichen und dann noch
einmal so eine
streichelnde Bewegung machen wichtig ist
dass wir das halt schön luftig und
fluffig unterrühren und nicht die ganze
Luft rausschlagen deswegen machen wir
jetzt auch mit der Hand weiter und nicht
mehr mit der Maschine
[Musik]
die trockenen Zutaten also mehl
Speisestärke und Backpulver habe ich
vorab in einem Sieb gegeben ein bisschen
verrührt damit es sich verbindet und
dann in vier bis fünf Schritten mit zur
Masse gegeben und untergehoben auch hier
wieder dieses unterheben das ist so
wichtig da würde ich jetzt auch kein
Schneebesen empfehlen und schaut mal wie
fluffig das ist ich liebe Biskuitboden
das gebe ich jetzt hier in meine 26er
Springform diesmal habe ich die mit
Backpapier ausgelegt ich habe ja keinen
ja ich habe Fett von den Eiern im Teig
aber kein richtiges Fett daher immer
lieber mit Backpapier benutzen Ofen habe
ich auch schon vorgeheizt auf 180 Grad
Ober und Unterhitze und dann backt der
Boden für ca 24 Minuten macht gerne die
Stäbchenprobe und lass ihn dann
anschließend zugedeckt vollständig
auskühlen
[Musik]
wir nutzen jetzt mal die Zwischenzeit
und machen die leckere Erdbeercreme
dafür nehme ich wieder die Maschine und
habe hier kalte Zutaten wichtig ist dass
die Zutaten jetzt in der richtigen
Reihenfolge in die Rührschüssel gegeben
werden und zwar starte ich jetzt hier
mit Mascarpone da könntet ihr auch
Doppelrahmen Frischkäse nehmen zum
Beispiel Philadelphia der schmeckt ja
auch sehr neutral und salzarm so da
könnt ihr dann jetzt schon Puderzucker
dazugeben ich sieht mein Puderzucker
jetzt nicht denn der hat bei mir jetzt
eigentlich keine Klümpchen wenn ihr
merkt durch Lagerung etc dann sind der
Klümpchen dann könnt ihr das auf jeden
Fall noch dazu sehen so da kann jetzt
auch schon Vanilleextrakt mit rein so
und dann rühren wir das für ein paar
Sekunden nicht zu lang und wird die
Mascarpone super flüssig also wirklich
nur für ein paar Sekunden und lassen
dann währenddessen kalte Schlagsahne
rein fließen und dann könnt ihr mit der
Power also mit der Geschwindigkeit ein
bisschen höher gehen und das ganze fast
komplett steif schlagen ich werde gleich
stoppen und zeige euch den Moment wo ihr
seht okay jetzt ist es fast steif und
dann kommt Nagellack dazu
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt auch noch Sahnefest
schon dazu gegeben und ihr seht dann
ganz schnell dass sobald ihr Sahnefest
auch dazu gibt dass sich ein Muster
bildet vom Schneebesen davor ist einfach
nur eine flüssige Masse und ihr merkt
dann auch irgendwann wirklich da kommt
dieses Schneebesen Muster aber es ist
noch nicht so fest dass ihr da jetzt
irgendwie mit einem Spritzbeutel eine
Rose Spritzen könnte weil das sehr sehr
leicht vom Teigschaber runterfällt und
das ist jetzt der Moment wo wir unseren
Magerquark dazu geben den gebe ich nicht
gerne vorher schon dazu sondern wirklich
ganz zum Schluss erst weil der nur noch
in den letzten 10 Sekunden die die Sahne
jetzt braucht zum komplett steif werden
da einfach nur noch mit reingegeben
werden soll also jetzt wirklich nur noch
zehn maximum 10 Sekunden verrühren und
dann ist die Creme auch komplett fest
[Musik]
da wir jetzt eine erdbeer-chiotto-torte
machen möchte ich diese aktuell
Vanillecreme umwandeln in eine schöne
Erdbeer Vanillecreme und dafür habe ich
Erdbeeren püriert ich habe jetzt einfach
Tiefkühlerdbeeren genommen die habe ich
eigentlich immer da ihr könnt auch
frische nehmen die Tiefkühler dann habe
ich nur kurz in die Mikrowelle getan
damit sie nicht ganz so fest sind sind
jetzt aber nicht warm also es ist immer
noch sehr sehr kalt und ich streich das
jetzt noch durch mein feines Haar sieht
weil ich persönlich mag das jetzt
einfach nicht auf diese kleinen Mini
Stückchen zu beißen daher einmal noch
rein passieren und dann noch mal
unterheben und dann kommt die Creme bis
zur Weiterverarbeitung in den
Kühlschrank wir warten ja noch darauf
dass der Boden auskühlt und dann geht's
weiter
[Musik]
so weiter geht's mit dem Schneiden und
Schichten also ich habe jetzt noch mal
einen Tipp für euch den gebe ich
eigentlich immer wieder den kennt ihr
eigentlich auch von mir dass wenn ihr
ein Küchentuch nass macht und ausbringt
und dann auf die Oberfläche gibt dann
trocknen die Oberfläche auch nicht aus
alternativ einfach abdecken aber ich mag
das ganz gerne so und jetzt wird einmal
der Springform Rand gelöst da könnt ihr
jetzt mit einer Palette
sicherheitshalber mit einer flachen
Winkelpalette einmal am Rand entlang
dass ihr euch da auch nichts weg reißt
ich mache das immer gerne einfach um auf
Nummer sicher zu gehen ich merke auch
schon dass der dass der Boden jetzt hier
wirklich noch ein bisschen am Rand und
fest saß und jetzt kann ich ganz einfach
den Rand abnehmen
so dann einmal umdrehen das ist auch
perfekt für zwei Böden also ich finde
die Höhe einfach ideal
so und jetzt wird der einmal in der
Hälfte durchgeteilt können wir mal bitte
darüber sprechen wie akkurat gerade das
ist oder was ist der Hammer ein bisschen
so und jetzt werde ich hier mein meine
tortensäge einmal einstellen und dann
durchsehen
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt unten drunter noch so
ein cakeboard gelegt einfach damit ich
später einfacher transportieren kann
hier habe ich die drehbare tortenplätze
dann kann ich einfach besser
verstreichen und dekorieren und meinen
ersten Boden habe ich hier schon mal in
den Tortenring gegeben bzw den
Tortenring außenrum geklemmt damit es
schön eng klemmen kann und ich einfach
alles schön gerade Schichten kann ohne
das was von den Seiten runter fließt ich
habe jetzt hier meine Haselnusscreme die
habe ich bei 600 Watt für ca 10 Sekunden
in der Mikrowelle erwärmt dann wird sie
so fies fähig sein und so kann ich
einfach besser verstreichen muss schon
sagen mein Haselnusscreme schmeckt
einfach nach toto viele sagen nach bueno
ich glaube wenn man den Geschmack von
bueno auch eher gewöhnt ist aber dadurch
dass es so intensiv schmeckt finde ich
immer noch das Giotto könnt ihr mal
reinschreiben was ihr findet ich glaube
das Gefühl die jeder aus der Kirche
schon probiert oder
nicht probiert hat das werde ich Ernstes
würde mich wirklich interessieren so
streichpalette oder halt auch eine
Winkelpalette könnt ihr nehmen und dann
einfach auf dem Boden streichen und
darüber gebe ich dann gleich eine dünne
dünne Schicht von der Creme dann kommen
fein gewürfelte Erdbeeren dazu ich
wollte gerne noch frische Erdbeeren in
der Torte haben und dann kommt weitere
Creme oben drauf die dünne Schicht dient
einfach so ein bisschen als Kleber für
die Erdbeeren und dann kommt weitere
Creme oben drüber
[Musik]
den zweiten Boden auch drauflegen und
dann weiter verfahren bis hier oben
angekommen seid ich habe jetzt hier noch
Creme für den Rand und für die
deko-spitzer übrig ich gebe euch noch
einen Tipp falls eure Erdbeeren sehr
sehr wässrig sein sollten könnt ihr und
ihr merkt ihr könnt mit der cremig gut
aufspritzen auch gerne noch ein bisschen
Sahnefest dazu geben also ein Päckchen
zwei Teelöffel wenn ihr merkt dass wir
dann immer noch nicht fest gerne noch
mehr Sahnefest dazu geben oder ihr nehmt
euch Zeit und kühlt die Creme richtig
also meine ist eigentlich schon ganz gut
fest aber ich gebe jetzt auch noch mal
in den Kühlschrank die Torte sollte auch
für mindestens 3 Stunden in den
Kühlschrank einfach damit alles schön
sitzt und sie euch auch nicht zerläuft
ihr könnt das auch gerne am Vortag
vorbereiten dann habt ihr keinen Stress
aber wie gesagt das ist jetzt 3 Stunden
kühlen und dann geht's weiter mit der
ähm weiteren Deko und ja bis gleich die
Kühlzeit ist rum und ich nehme jetzt
hier einmal die Torte runter ich habe ja
das cakeboard unten drunter da kann ich
das ganz leicht anheben und gibt das
hier auf meine Tortenplatte
so die gebe ich jetzt aber der
Einfachheit halber wieder auf die
drehbare Tortenplatte einfach damit ich
es besser verstreichen kann und da kommt
jetzt das tortenringmesser zum Einsatz
damit ich mir die Seiten nicht weg reiße
also bei der Springform dadurch dass die
beschichtet ist benutze ich es nicht da
habe ich leider nicht den Vorteil aber
beim Tortenring ist das immer ein super
Vorteil dass diese ultra Klinge ist das
ideal um jetzt den Tortenring einfach zu
lösen
so und jetzt werden die Seiten
verstrichen wir haben ja noch Creme
übrig die reicht jetzt genau für die
Seiten noch und den Rest fülle ich mir
dann in einen Spritzbeutel und mach noch
schöne Tupfer oben drauf
[Musik]
ja ich habe es geschafft dass die
tortenfarbe exakt so aussieht wie die
Tortenplatte so richtig Ton den Ton auch
wenn ich meine Tortenplatte Liebe muss
sie leider weichen es tut mir leid aber
ich entscheide mich für eine weiße
Tortenplatte also es fühlt sich einmal
um und dann wird das verstrichen
[Musik]
ich bin traurig ich habe einfach zwei
Stücke von diesem genialen Kuchen und
haben sie es nicht da also eigentlich
war das unser Stück aber er ist gerade
nicht da er ist nämlich bei uns im Café
und gönnt sich wahrscheinlich dort sonst
Sebastian Cheesecake ich mache mal den
Test für euch ich muss sagen dass der
Anschnitt wirklich wunderschön aussieht
also die Linien sind einfach akkurat
gerade obwohl ich mir gar nicht so viel
Mühe gegeben habe beim gerade machen das
funktioniert halt irgendwie immer oh da
kam die Haselnuss durch oh lecker der
Haselnussgeschmack bzw der Giotto
Geschmack weil es ist wirklich unsere
Creme schmeckt einfach wie die Füllung
von Giotto ist extrem obwohl ich nur die
Böden bestrichen habe es ist extrem also
ihr beißt rein ihr habt diese fluffige
Erdbeercreme und dann kommt ihr wirklich
zu diesem zu der Haselnusscreme das
schmeckt super es ist eine tolle
Kombination es schmeckt total
erfrischend und ich glaube fast dass ich
zwei Stücke verdrücken könnte auf jeden
Fall doch ich liebe es richtig gut also
macht unbedingt nach ich werde dem haben
sie auf jeden Fall sein Stückchen
aufbewahren und dann hoffe ich dass wir
uns auch beim nächsten mal wiedersehen
und dir meinen Kanal auch fleißig
abonniert habt damit ihr nämlich solche
Rezepte auch nicht mehr verpasst also
dann bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss
[Musik]